we're told that H of X is equal to 3x G
of T is equal to negative 2 t minus 2
minus H of T f of n is equal to negative
5 n squared plus h of n so we have 3
function definitions and two of these
function definitions are actually
defined in terms of another function in
particular in terms of the function H
and then we're asked to calculate what
is H of G of 8 and this can be very
daunting but we just have to remember
that all a function is is something that
takes an input and gives you an output
for it and this is another way this this
somewhat convoluted looking statement is
another way of saying look we're going
to take the number 8 we're going to take
the number 8 and we are going to input
it into the function G we are going to
input it into the function G and then
that is going to produce G of 8 that is
going to produce G of 8 and then we're
going to take whatever value that is and
input that into the function H so we're
going to take this whole thing and
they're going to input that into the
function H and what we will have will be
H of H of what we inputted H of G of H
of G of 8 so let's just do it one step
at a time let's figure out what G of 8
is so G of 8 g of an I'm going to color
code it so we can keep track of things G
of 8 is equal to well G of T we have our
definition here so our input now instead
of eight is going to be our T so our
input is 8 so every place where we see a
t in this function definition we replace
it with an 8 so it's going to be
negative 2 times 8 negative 2 times 8
minus 2 minus 2 minus and this might be
a little daunting but let's just replace
this T with an 8 and then see if we can
make sense of it h minus let me do it in
the right color minus 2 minus 2 minus H
of H of 8 notice to evaluate G of 8 all
we did is everywhere we saw T we
replaced it with the in
eight now let's see if we can calculate
this this is going to be equal to
negative two times eight is negative 16
minus two is negative 18 do that same so
this is going to be equals negative 18
minus what is H of 8 going to be equal
to so let's do that over here so H of 8
this thing H of 8 now we go to the
definition of H don't worry about later
we're going to input all this business
into H again just let's worry about it
one step at a time we need to calculate
H of 8 so H of 8 is just going to be
well every time we see an X we replace
it with an 8 it's going to be 3 times 8
which is equal to 24 so this value right
over here is 24 we are subtracting it so
we have minus minus 24 negative 18 minus
24 is what that's negative 42 so this
all of this business is going to be
equal to did I do that right yeah
negative negative 42 so we figured out
what G of 8 is it is negative 42 so this
right over here is negative 42 and now
we can input negative 42 into H so H of
H I've let me do it right over here H of
negative 42 H of negative 42 remember
negative 42 is the same thing as G of 8
so this is H of G of 8 is the same thing
as H of negative 42 this is going to be
equal to that same color this is going
to be equal to 3 3 times negative 42 3
times negative 42 which is equal to
which is equal to this is negative 126
negative 126 and we are done so it
seemed convoluted at first but if you
just keep track of what's our input
what's our output and just really just
evaluate the functions it should
hopefully be reasonably straightforward